[upbeat intro music]
Hello, psych2goers!
We just want to take the time to thank you
for all your kind support.
We are a team of dedicated, passionate, and hardworking individuals
who come together every day with one goal in mind:
We want to make psychology come alive for you.
We are self-funded, and recently launched our Patreon
If you enjoy the work we do and find it meaningful,
please stick around until the end of the video
for more information on how to get more involved with us
and all the cool rewards you can get from us.
We hope you enjoy this video.
Childhood abuse can develop into lifelong issues
from insecurity to intimacy issues.
Depending on the severity,
it can also cause a person to suffer Post-Traumatic Stress Disorder
(PTSD).
Along with mental health awareness,
our team also wants to take a stand
and educate the public about the dangerous effects of child abuse.
Some of the information we are about to share
might be triggering.
So we advise our viewers to be careful.
If you or someone you know is being abused,
we advise you to call your emergency hotline immediately for help.
Here are six types of child abuse.
One: Name-calling and other forms of verbal abuse.
While some people may argue and say that words may never hurt them,
words often can and do hurt,
especially when you're young.
Harsh words from a parent or guardian has even greater ability to hurt.
One study by Johnson, Cohen, and others
suggest that verbal child abuse can increase the risk
of the victim developing personality disorders.
Research by Teicher and colleagues
also shows that verbal abuse can negatively alter development of the brain.
As a result, verbal abuse can have serious physical effects on the child.
Two: Shaming
Shaming people for something that isn't wrong
is an abusive behavior parents can inflict on their kids to gain control.
It causes the victim to develop insecurities
which parents can use to get what they want
if they find that their child is disobeying them.
Over time, this causes the child to lose trust in their caretaker.
As they grow up,
they may also become hesitant
in developing social connections with people
afraid that one day they will be betrayed or hurt.
Three: Extreme helicopter parenting.
Helicopter parenting is different from being a pushy parent.
Extreme helicopter parenting occurs
when parents are so overbearing
that children do not have any say in even minor details.
Parents who constantly check in on their child
make it difficult for the child to learn healthy boundaries.
Furthermore, if children are pushed too far emotionally or physically,
they can develop physical or mental scars.
Four: Sexual abuse.
Sexual abuse, however explicit or implicit,
can cause long-lasting harmful effects on the child.
The child may suffer from Post-Traumatic Stress Disorder,
and can close themselves off completely,
afraid of getting into relationships.
This can cause them to fear intimacy
As a result, it's not just loneliness or alienation
that they will experience growing up--
but they will never feel safe again
because their caretaker took that away.
Five: Neglect.
Not providing a child with proper emotional or physical needs
can lead to many problems down the road.
The child may become emotionally, socially, or psychologically underdeveloped.
But neglect of physical and security needs,
such as food and proper shelter,
can also cause damage to the child's physical health.
Depending on the severity,
it can even result in immediate death.
Six: Physical abuse.
Physical abuse involves any harmful activity
that causes a person to feel pain.
Kicking, slapping, hitting, throwing, biting, and choking
are only a few to name.
The child may develop cuts, scars, bruises, broken bones, or even death,
depending on how badly they were beaten.
Never allow someone to hit you or excuse the action
even if they apologize.
Please call for help from the police before things get more out of hand.
Which types of child abuse have you heard about?
Did you find this helpful?
We know this isn't an easy topic to talk about,
but hope that any brave discussions you share below
could bring our community closer.
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from psych2go
and check out our Patreon.
We started it because we wanted to grow into a bigger platform
that reaches more people that are in need of help.
With your contribution,
you can receive our psy pendant, t-shirt,
issues of our magazine,
and many more membership benefits.
Your funding will help us produce quality scripting,
voiceovers, and animation,
that makes our content both entertaining,
AND educational.
We want to make sure
our community members get the best
and only the best.
Thanks for watching!
Hey, everybody!
I just want to give a personal thank-you video
for you guys for always supporting psych2go
and making this all possible for us.
Our vision  is to make psychology as accessible as possible
so that it promotes self-awareness and helps you guys grow.
However, we want to make more content for you guys,
and would love your support in buying one of these bracelets
from our partner, Introvert Palace.
Check out the bracelet; it's pretty cool,
and it even includes Pluto!
The link to purchase will be all in the description below,
and I hope you guys have an amazing day.
Bye!